dès les premières minutes de l'événement
le ton était donné l'adaptation au
changement climatique
c'est la priorité numéro 1 de la
population aucun chef n'allait pouvoir
éviter le sujet chaud sur ce parterre
bondé d'élus municipaux c'est l'élection
de la dernière chance gabriel nadeau
dubois en a profité pour éventer sa
promesse du jour créé des sociétés
d'état pour le transport par train et
par autobus dans la province y en a qui
prétendent que le transport en commun ça
va endetter nos enfants mais pas le
troisième ligne paul st pierre plamondon
a aussi sorti le chéquier il promet 30
milliards de dollars pour que les villes
développent leur propre système de
transport en commun si vous la solution
ce sera vos projets et nos budgets sont
au rendez vous ça voudrait dire qu'il
faudrait sacrifier des construction
d'hôpitaux d'écoles les projets
solidaires et péquistes qui ne sont pas
réalistes affirme françois legault car
il manque de travailleurs pour accélérer
les projets de construction
mais le chef de la caq en lui-même du
rétro pédaler sur un autre sujet je suis
moins catégorique que ce qui a été écrit
par les journalistes il faut qu'on
respecte la capacité de payer des
québécois en début de semaine il n'était
pas trop chaud à l'idée de donner 2
milliards de dollars aux municipalités
pour qu'elles s'adaptent aux changements
climatiques
devant les maires et mairesses il se dit
maintenant prêt à discuter d'un pacte
vert comme tous les autres chefs y
compris éric duhaime on propose nous de
financer notre transition énergétique en
exploitant nos hydrocarbures
quand j'entends
certaines personnes nous dire que ça
coûte beaucoup d'argent que de faire
cette lutte de cette adaptation il ya
aussi un énorme coup à l'inertie des
réponses qui sonnent comme de la musique
aux oreilles des principaux intéressés
je monte entendu collaboration
partenariat revoir la fiscalité être
ouvert à discuter le message a été
entendu
on a des engagements clairs de leur part
hormis l'environnement d'autres sujets
chers aux villes comme la fiscalité
municipale et la crise du logement ont
été abordés aujourd'hui mais chose
certaine le prochain ou la prochaine à
devenir premier ministre aura fort à
faire pour répondre à toutes les
attentes des maires et mairesses du
québec ici alexandre duval radio canada
montréal